after more than a decade the wait is
almost over because apple is finally
bringing us another display that is
going to be affordable like their
previous thunderbolt display was and it
looks like we're gonna have three and
maybe possibly four displays coming out
with a variety of sizes and price points
so today we'll cover all the displays
that are coming out including one that
will have an egpu built into it the
features and the specs of these and the
likely price points as well people have
been asking for a new apple display ever
since apple discontinued their
thunderbolt display in 2016
and gave people an lg option that really
didn't compare now i was a person who
bought that right away with the
redesigned 2016 macbook pro and while it
was a nice 5k screen with a panel that
matched their 5k imax because it
literally was the same exact display it
really didn't compare because the build
quality didn't look good uh didn't feel
good the display was very wobbly on that
stand and it just wasn't the same as
apples now of course they did give us
the xdr 6k display which i've been using
now for probably about to see almost two
years or so but most people can't afford
a six thousand 000 display and they have
no need for one now we have had rumors
of a new apple display coming for a
while but recently we have much more
concrete information dylan dkt recently
said that there are three lg made
displays encased in unbranded enclosures
for usage as external monitors that are
in early development two of which have
had the same exact specs as the upcoming
27-inch redesigned imac and the 24 inch
imac that we already currently have and
with that we also have mark german's
report that is very similar talking
about apple working on a lower price
monitor that they will sell alongside
the pro display xdr which is of course
what all of us want and it makes sense
with apple finally putting effort into
the mac mini which we're waiting on the
mac mini pro and then alongside of that
we are going to have an updated mac pro
as well and all these new macbooks and
imacs which really need a nice display
now right now even six years later apple
is still selling that lg ultraviolet 5k
for the same
hundred dollar price now it's
interesting that lg which partnered with
apple to create this ultra fine lineup
for apple's max also recently released
two displays a 27 inch and a 32 inch and
even though it's using the same branding
the same style apple they're not selling
this display on their website so if this
was the next replacement it would make
sense for them to also sell it as well
but they are not and that's another
reason why we know the apple they are
they're making their own displays and
they're going to be releasing them soon
now let's get into the details of these
displays the first one is going to be a
24 inch size now on apple's website they
sell the lg ultra fine 4k display for
700. so it's not crazy expensive but it
still isn't cheap now if you look over
here it says literally currently
unavailable and pick up unavailable as
well so it's interesting that even
though it's on here you're not able to
order it now of course we have the new
m1 imacs that came out and they have a
slightly smaller size it's actually 23.5
inches
but the resolution is actually higher so
it's a different panel inside of the
imac and lg they are the ones that make
these displays for apple so what we are
expecting is basically something that
looks very similar to that imac but
without that chin with the same exact
mount the same design something that's
easy for apple to manufacture and then
the same exact display that is in there
and that would be a great option for
people who want to buy a mac mini
who or who just want to buy a macbook
air or pro and also want a smaller
display at a reasonable price and
something that's going to have good
color accuracy and brightness now the
second display that a lot of people are
focusing on is of course that 27 inch
size we know that apple is working on
the 27 inch imac and also the imac pro
which may or may not be the same device
or they could split it up
but we have conflicting info on the
display some people are just saying lcd
which is what we have in that lg
ultrafine 5k and then we also have very
specific info from ross young who is a
display analyst talking about a new mini
led display for the imac pro that will
have about a thousand zones and about 4
000 mini leds now that is actually
better quality and higher density and
more zones than my 6k pro display xdr
and then of course we have talks about
pro motion as well some people are
saying that it could cost about fifteen
hundred dollars and some other people
are saying up to twenty five hundred
dollars which is a lot cheaper than
their five thousand dollar display with
a thousand dollar stand but still way
too expensive now the 1500 price point
makes quite a bit of sense because it's
200 more than what lg's ultra fine is
selling for right now and apple they
have been raising their prices on their
latest products and of course with that
we would have a nicer quality display
that's apple branded so i think that's
reasonable but it's hard to imagine
getting that display with mini led for
that price point now the people are
saying 2500
that is more in line with the mini led
built into it and who knows maybe if
apple was making a separate imac pro
that does offer mini led and the base
imac has regular led
then you could have another option or
maybe a second display listing for that
mini led feature now if we look at the
market there are a lot of good displays
but any display that is capable of such
high brightness for hdr color grading
you start getting the four thousand and
five thousand dollar territory for 4k
displays so if apple does release a
display for 2500 with many led it would
actually be a pretty good deal now of
course we also have the info on the new
updated pro display xdr and it is going
to have to have a lot of updates the
latest info that we're getting on it is
that it will have a dedicated a13 chip
and a neural engine built into the
display
which will be effectively used as an
e-gpu
and this info has been around for a long
time we've had leaks of this back from
2016
with having a display with the
integrated gpu now that might may not
make a lot of sense why would they have
something that's limited but if we're
thinking about an a13 or maybe even an
a15 chip at this point
they that would give apple a lot of
capabilities for this display
for example it could have airplay 2
support it could potentially have face
id the new features for facetime if it
just has that built-in webcam which we
would expect have sidecar support and
probably graphics processing if you
connect it to a display that isn't
capable of the 120 hertz pro motion and
the mini led hdr brightness or
resolutions with higher refresh rates if
you connect to older macs
they might not have the capability and
then also connecting to macs that have
just intel processors in general we've
seen that there are limitations and
having this chip be built into that
display would fix that because we know
the apple they're working on a
redesigned mac pro not only the smaller
form factor with the apple silicon chip
but also another intel model that will
be launching and with that intel model
they're going to be releasing that for
people that still need certain features
that don't run an apple silicon or
potential hardware for example up to 1.5
terabytes of ram which you're not going
to be able to get with the apple silicon
version
now with the intel max there are certain
features that you actually flat out
can't use with macos monterrey because
you need the processing of the apple
silicon chip to be able to enable that
for example we have portrait mode with
the facetime camera that's built into
that display things with maps object
capture siri text to speech dictation
all these things that use the neural
engine to accelerate it that just flat
out won't work on intel based mac so if
they put this chip into the display no
matter what you connect it to you will
have all the features and it will just
use that to process it
so there you guys go we have three
displays coming out let me know which
one are you gonna be most interested for
will you spend up to twenty five hundred
dollars for a 27 inch that has mini led
or is that too high would you rather
prefer an apple version of the lg ultra
fine without many changes we're excited
to see that we're excited for apple's
march event you guys can check out a
couple great videos right over there
this has been max and i'll see you in
the next video
[Music]
you